this video is sponsored by honey the
browser extension that gets you the best
prices on everything you buy online
[Music]
hey wisecrack jared here with our third
and final exploration of Christopher
Nolan's weird wild mind and our first
installment we examine Nolan's idea of
the self charting the relationships
between our subjective perceptions and
the notion of objective reality
unfortunately our investigation still
came too late to save poor teddy in the
second installment we use no one's Dark
Knight trilogy to discuss the fragile
dynamics of society and the ways in
which social norms are tested and
upended by symbols by desire and all too
often by hulking weirdos in masks and
now in our third act we'll attempt to
find some catharsis by looking to the
universe for a response to the fragile
nature of humanity I want to know where
we are so strap in because this is the
final installment of the philosophy of
Christopher Nolan oh and we'll be
answering your questions for the first
hour in the comments so we'll see you
there and of course spoilers ahead
whereas no one's previous works focused
on the inevitable conflict inherent in
humanity's rational nature interstellar
attempts to transcend these burdens by
looking to the broad expanses of the
universe and hopes of ridding us from
these social and physical restraints
explored in videos 1 and 2 of this
series by merging a sense of wide-eyed
wonder with the thrilling advancements
of science no one helps Cooper and us
break free of the expectations leveled
against the self and society from as
early as its opening scenes interstellar
situates its protagonist Cooper as
ambitious innovator but also as a
clear-eyed advocate for science and
reason I record the facts handle I get
to that on the Y and present your
conclusions he's also a guy with a
pretty healthy skepticism of power and
authority it's an old federal textbook
we've replaced them with the corrected
versions corrected but before the film's
Adventure is done with him Cooper will
have to reconcile his data-driven
beliefs with the mind expanding
unpredictability of the great beyond
although Cooper is firmly committed to
his own sense of practicality he is
eventually forced to navigate the fluid
boundary between the real and the irreal
latter of which is a concept introduced
by American philosopher and Nelson
Goodman but what is the areal exactly in
his work the ways of world making
Goodman explored the notion of
alternative world versions at its most
basic interpretation this concept
allowed for everything from art to
mathematics to be perceived and
understood in a variety of ways take a
look at this piece of art for example
and you might see a woman's face or a
goblet both interpretations here are
correct in total but only one
interpretation is correct through one
particular context at a time and this in
essence is the art of a reality there
are multiple ways to look at the world
and no one method is better in every
instance as such the way the film's
mysterious beings experience the
universe opens up a space for a new way
to experience and know the universe just
not in the way were used to with you
know time is a thing that passes in
space Cooper is confronted with the
areal nothing abides by his conventional
ideas of time or even cause-and-effect
Cooper as a man of science has some
difficulty adjusting to a new normal and
through that difficult adjustment no one
has openly able to question the physical
spatial and chronological laws that we
and Cooper have long believed to be
absolute throughout much of interstellar
time and space do not interact with us
in a way we might traditionally expect
and neither as it turns out does
all-american hero Matt Damon on a new
plane of existence in which even time
can be warped gravity on that planet
will slow our clock compared to Earth's
drastically every hour we spend on that
planet will be seven years back on earth
what asks Nolan is left to ground us
humans
what lighthouse is there to help us
navigate to give us purpose and
direction thankfully interstellar not
only poses this question it provides an
answer and that answer is the one place
technology cannot touch human emotion
although the characters of interstellar
frequently doubt what is real and what
is trustworthy there's not filled tear
trench deeply emotional experiences
provide them with the ballast focus and
resolve to see their adventure through
to the end and those components of
humanity are the very
sorts of things science alone can't
provide in fact near the beginning of
the film it suggested the crash landing
that stalled Cooper's aviation career
was a result of his reliance on
technology alone but ultimately it's
human connection and emotion
encapsulated in dr. brands love for dr.
Edmonds
love is the one thing we're capable of
perceiving that transcends dimensions of
time and space that leads this crew to
the habitable planet they so desperately
seek now that's not to say the film is
anti science far from it instead it
demonstrates something more complex that
science is necessary but by itself is an
insufficient condition for a journey of
discovery science alone can't solve our
problems of limited resources identity
or societal violence an interstellar
science needs something more
it needs emotion it needs love to fuel
and guide it it requires human
subjectivity that launches us beyond
facts and figures and shiny chrome they
have access to infinite time in space
but they're not bound by anything they
can't find a specific place in time
they can't communicate it Swami and in
that sense interstellar represents
something of a capstone in the
Christopher Nolan experience in the face
of the questions of identity that arise
from myself and from society
interstellar responds by showing how
scientific advancements merged with the
intangibles of the human experience
provide us with the necessary thrust
toward new frontiers and personal
liberation if there's an answer here on
earth it's back there
somehow in that room of course the
technology exhibited in interstellar is
not of today's world it's instead rooted
in speculative fiction and that's where
the film itself even acts as an elegant
marriage of science and imagination it
shows us worlds and innovations we've
never seen before with interstellar
christopher nolan confronts us with the
power of high personal cinema image
driven storytelling of an imagined
future that can influence and
emotionally fuel us in the present and
that future urges us to make the a real
real even if we have to crawl to the
uncertainties of time and space to do it
at least were fueled by love along the
way with interstellar no one presents
new worlds and realities that push us
far from the violent self-destructive
climate of the Dark Knight trilogy or
lamento and in these new worlds no one
offers us an optimistic glimpse of our
own possible future so why did he follow
this story with Dunkirk a film about the
Allied evacuation from bloody wartime
conflict in 1940 the short answer
perhaps is that Dunkirk is about our
future too in both interstellar and
Dunkirk
Nolan unites his audience in celebrating
the indomitable spirit of the human the
notion that man and woman is essentially
good the notion that each of us is built
to persevere this is evidence in much of
Christopher Nolan's recent work
including the Dark Knight Rises
when Catwoman tells Batman she's bailing
and assures him she's no hero I'll open
that tunnel then I'm gone only to prove
herself wrong in the eleventh hour how
sweet interstellar furthers this
cheerful embrace of human decency and
capability by using love to push Cooper
all the way to the end of his journey
Cooper's own indomitable spirit
powerfully fueled by the love for his
daughter proves enough to ensure his
success what could be a clear example of
that emotional potency that unflappable
will to persevere then what the British
refer to as the Dunkirk spirit a term
that's been used to convey solidarity
since the days of that bloody battle in
World War two the Dunkirk spirit is
defined by a sense of community a
willingness by a group of people who are
in a bad situation to all help each
other the film invests a deep sense of
communal spirit a spirit best embodied
in mr. Dawson despite lacking any
military technology this guy pilots his
small
into violent conflict commits himself to
saving the lives of strangers and
emerges victorious thanks to the sheer
power of will contender uh we have a job
to do mr. Dawson's instrumentation is
not technical but internal the step
beyond interstellar and the purest
possible connection between the self
society and the spiritual unknown much
like dr. Amelia brand and interstellar
mr. Dawson is resolutely piloted by love
but while mr. Dawson was unable to save
his son he is in a sense still able to
save the conceptual image of his son
with each life mr. Dawson rescues during
the Dunkirk escape how do you know that
stuff anyway my son is one of you luck I
knew each sister and you know what that
achievement might just be something even
more noble and significant in the realm
of the indomitable human spirit
Dunkirk suggests sometimes the irreal is
more real than real not only is this
seen in the choices the characters make
but in the way the film is constructed
Dunkirk is structured in such a way as
to reveal the purest distillation of
this communal concept I didn't want to
tell the story in words I didn't want
people I didn't want the theatrics of
people
telling the audience why you should care
about i wanted to care about them just
because of the physical situation that
they were in where many of Nolan's
previous films have been criticized for
being too long to dialogue heavy into
expository dunkirk clocks in and only
107 minutes offers back story for almost
none of its characters and really
doesn't have much interest in
conversation in other words no one
created a sense of solidarity between
the viewers and soldiers without relying
on the tools often used to draw an
audience's essentially it plunks us here
with every bullet fired and with every
ship destroyed Dunkirk aims to access
the psychological concept of effective
empathy the ability not just to know or
to understand what someone is feeling
but to feel that feeling before it
occurs in interviews about the
production of Dunkirk
no one said his ambition was to create
virtual reality without the headset in
other words a fully effective experience
for the viewer
whether Nolan's successfully reached
this goal is up to each individual
viewer to decide but the blending of
science technology and imagination to
create an immersive sense of
participation in the Dunkirk spirit
well that might just be no one's loudest
call to each of us do bind together in
shaping and perfecting the self society
and future that we want
no one's most recent film didn't just
bring him a boatload of Oscar
nominations it also brought together the
threads of his earlier work ultimately
illustrating the power of love and the
human spirit Christopher Nolan is one of
the most interesting filmmakers working
today
his movies aren't only visceral and
exciting but also extremely thoughtful a
rare blend in today's Hollywood this is
merely our interpretation of his work
but as with any master craftsman his
work will continue to inspire new
thought for years to come thanks for
watching guys hope you enjoyed our
Christopher Nolan trilogy peace hey
wisecrack want to save money without the
extra effort add honey to your browser
to get started today honey is a free
browser extension that searches the web
for coupons and discounts they can help
you save money on your online purchases
honey does all the legwork so you don't
have to spend time looking for coupon
codes with honey you always pay the
lowest price for everything you buy
online adding honey to your browser is
easy it just takes two clicks and you
only
to do it once go to join honey calm /
wisecrack click add honey and you're
good to go
shop at your favorite stores online and
watch the savings pile up here we are
getting a sweet discount on some treats
from our new favorite store ticks by
mail and of course we can't pass up
unruhe stocking our delicious cereal
wall luckily honey always test coats to
make sure you're getting the cheapest
price so there's no reason not to add
honey to your browser today it's free
takes just two clicks to install and
will save you money so click the link
below to add honey to your browser for
free or go to join honeycomb / wisecrack
and as always thanks for watching guys
peace